What's the new world?
Go to the treasure
[Music] [
Music]
Otaku hero I
want to love what I like as much as I like
What's wrong with that? After all,
you're essential to this game. Do
n't you have something you like?
I love creating worlds, and I've risked my entire
being to create this game, to
deny and eradicate the family that denied me.I
finally understood, you're the one that all otakus
have.  Things are as good as
dead without them No matter
who expects them or
how much they deny them, they can't be
stopped I like
anime I like things I like plastic
models I like music Everyone
idols, special effects, figures, etc.  I
love cosplay, the military, railroad models, and erotic doujinshi because I can
feel the soul of the person who created them.It's an irresistible
impulse that resonates with me, but
this game is different.
[Music] My
child likes me, and that kind of
thing steals our company. It's exactly
like the video.
Do your best
[Music] I'll
give back the world.